[Music]
here we go
good morning colleagues the 9031st
meeting of the security council is
called to order
the provisional agenda for this meeting
is reports of the secretary general on
the sudan and south sudan
the agenda is adopted
the security council will now begin its
consideration of item two of the agenda
members of the council have before them
document s slash
2022-387
the text of a draft resolution submitted
by the united states of america
the council is ready to proceed to the
vote on the draft resolution that is
before it
i shall put the draft resolution to the
vote now
will those in favor of the draft
resolution contained in document s
2022-387
please raise their hand
the result of the voting is as follows
the draft resolution received 15 votes
in favor
the draft resolution has been adopted
unanimously as resolution
keep 2630-2022 i now will give the floor
to those members of the council who have
asked to make statements after the vote
i give the floor to the representative
of the russian federation
precedent
they are not
in
foreign
i thank the representative of the
russian federation for his statement
there are no more names inscribed on the
list of speakers
the meeting is adjourned
so
[Music]
good morning colleagues the
9032nd meeting of the security council
is called to order
the provisional agenda for this meeting
is maintenance of peace and security of
ukraine
the agenda is adopted
in accordance with rule 37 of the
council's provisional rules or procedure
i invite the representatives of ukraine
estonia
poland and slovakia to participate in
this meeting
it is so decided
in accordance with rule 39 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
i invite the following briefers to
participate in this meeting
miss joyce masuya assistant secretary
general for humanitarian affairs and
deputy emergency relief coordinator
and mr omar abdi deputy executive
director for programs unicef
it is so decided
thank you mr president
as this council
received an in-depth humanitarian
briefing by under secretary general
griffiths last thursday i will keep
today's remarks brief
and i know omar the deputy executive
director of unicef will of course
provide details on the impact of this
war is having on children
let me update you with the latest on the
united nations joint efforts to
negotiate more humanitarian poses to
allow safe passage for civilians trapped
by the fighting
on monday
we together with the international
committee of the red cross were able to
evacuate another
174 civilians
from the azov style steel plant
and other parts of mario paul
this was the third operation in the past
week out of mario paul
bringing the total number of civilians
evacuated from the steel plant
mario paul and neighboring towns to over
600
a truly monumental feat amid the
shelling and destruction ongoing in the
east
mr president
this is a glimmer of hope
yet as we have seen this past couple of
days
this war continues
on its destructive path
the intense fighting is causing immense
human suffering
civilians particularly women and
children are paying the heaviest price
recent reports of the shelling of a
school in belo horizon in luhansk oblast
where women and children were seeking
shelter from the fighting are abominable
and the human toll must be
condemned hostilities in populated areas
are extremely destructive
the use of wide area explosive weapons
in these areas comes with a very high
risk of indiscriminate effects and must
be avoided
the presence of landmine and unexploded
oldness
has also significantly impacts
humanitarian responses and access
even before this war eastern ukraine was
one of the most mine contaminated
regions in the world
support for mine action is crucial
demining is a priority to open up
humanitarian space
mr president
under international humanitarian law the
parties must respect all civilians as
well as civilian homes
schools hospitals and other essential
infrastructure
they must take constant care to spare
them
this includes allowing civilians to
leave areas of hostilities voluntarily
and safely
it includes having special consideration
for the needs of people
facing specific risks such as women
children the elderly and people with
disabilities
i also urge parties to the conflict to
remove any barriers to the movement of
humanitarian staff to ensure the
continued delivery of life-saving
assistance across ukraine
mr president
let me briefly update you on the latest
figures
almost 14 million ukrainians have been
forced to flee their homes of whom 8
million are internally displaced
227
partners the majority national ngos have
provided humanitarian assistance to over
5.4 million people many of those in the
east
this scale-up is unprecedented
as you are aware in addition to the
evacuations from the azov style plant in
mario paul
five inter-agency convoys including
essential
medical supplies water food rations
non-food items water repair systems and
generator have provided a lifeline to
civilians in cycled by fighting
this is by no means
enough both parties have been notified
of this convoys
i urge them to continue their
facilitation efforts so we can reach
many more civilians
this is also required of them under
international humanitarian law
we must urgently take our efforts to
scale
mr president
our recent efforts to evacuate civilians
in the east has shown us that there is
good will and common ground for us to
build on between the parties
as requested by the secretary general
martin is exploring ways to bring the
parties together to discuss humanitarian
issues including safe passage for
civilians and the movement of
humanitarian convoys
earlier this week
martin was warmly received in ankara by
the minister of foreign affairs
his excellency melvolt cabo slog
cabo so glue and presidential
spokesperson ibrahim khalid
their discussions focused on turkish
support to the un's efforts towards
progress on pressing humanitarian
concerns in ukraine
we must explore all options to reach
more people where needs are the greatest
we remain firmly committed to leaving no
stone unturned
to find measures from local poses to
wider ceasefires to save lives
the world's the world expects this of us
the people of ukraine deserves this
thank you mr president
i thank miss masuya for her briefing
i now give the floor to mr omar abdi
thank you mr president excellencies i
would like first to express our
appreciation
to ambassadors de la fuente and riviere
for convening today's meeting
i would also like to thank the united
states for hosting this briefing during
your security council presidency
it has been just one month since unicef
last briefed this council on the
situation of children in ukraine
as each day passes more ukrainian
children are exposed to the horrors of
this war
and just this past month the u.n
verified that nearly 100 children were
killed
and we believe the actual figure is to
be considerably higher
more children have been injured and
faced great violations of their rights
millions more have been displaced
schools continue to be attacked and used
for military purposes and water and
sanitation infrastructure impacted
the war in ukraine like all wars is a
child protection and child rights crisis
last month unicef briefed this council
following the attack on kramator's train
station
an attack on families fleeing the
violence
and which interrupted the work of our
team on the ground to deliver
desperately needed humanitarian
assistance
we meet again today after another
horrifying attack this time on a school
in luhansk
yet another stark example of this regard
for civilian lives
today even more families are mourning
the loss of loved ones it is also a
stark reminder that in ukraine today
education is also under attack
in february the school year came to a
standstill when the war broke out
as of last week at least 15 of 89 units
have supported schools in eastern
ukraine had been damaged or destroyed
since the start of the war
hundreds of schools across the country
are reported to have been hit
by heavy artillery airstrikes and other
explosive weapons in populated areas
while other schools are being used as
information centers
shelters supply hubs or for military
purposes with long-term impact on
children's return to education
these attacks must stop
all parts must honor their legal and
moral obligation to protect civilians
and civilian infrastructure
to respect international humanitarian
and human rights law and to ensure the
rights of children are upheld
in 2021 this council adopted resolution
2601 which condemns attacks on schools
and calls for all necessary safeguards
to uphold the right to education
the safe schools declaration outlines
what is needed to enhance the protection
of education in conflict what is needed
now is the courage discipline and
political will to translate these words
into action
excellencies schools are a lifeline for
children especially in conflict
schools are a safe place with routines
provided protection from harm
and a semblance of normalcy
schools are also critical conduits for
information about the risk of deadly
explosive ordinance
and they are a connector to essential
health and psychosocial services
the education workforce in ukraine
teachers principals social workers
psychologists and other professionals
are equally impacted by this conflict
supporting them so they can stay and
deliver is more important than ever
we must also ensure creative
multifaceted and flexible solutions that
combine low and high-tech methods to
reach all children and minimize
disruptions to their learning
in mid-march over fifteen thousand
schools resumed education in ukraine
mostly through remote learning or
in-person hybrid options
the ministry of education and science
supported by unicef and other partners
is doing everything possible to reach
ukrainian children including supporting
online education from kindergarten
through grade 11.
we are also supporting an ongoing
digital campaign on explosive ordinance
risk education while providing education
related supplies
however remote learning can only be a
temporary solution
from the pandemic
that's covered 19 pandemic show the
importance of children learning in a
school setting with their peers and
teachers
in the broader region thanks to the
european union's temporary protection
directive
governments and municipalities in
neighboring countries are in law are
enrolling children in national school
systems and alternative education
pathways
this is helping ensure the continuity of
children's learning and supporting their
completion of the school year
it is estimated that 3.7 million
children in ukraine and abroad are using
online and distance learning options
but enormous obstacles remain including
capacity and resource constraints
language barriers and unpredictable
movements of children and their families
we must make every effort to reach those
most at risk of being left behind for
the youngest learners access to
education can be especially challenging
less than five percent of the refugee
preschool preschool aged children are
estimated to be enrolled in public
kindergarten
children with disabilities need access
to inclusive services and assistive
technology as well as targeted programs
to cover their specific needs including
rehabilitation
in the last month we have seen small
moments of relief as children and other
civilians evacuated from mario paul and
other frontline locations reach relative
safety
humanitarians have reached millions of
people in need across the country with
health education
water and essential supplies as well as
information counseling and psychosocial
support
yet we know that the situation for
children and their families in
conflict-affected areas without access
to humanitarian assistance continues to
be grim
children and parents tell us of their
living hell
where they were forced to go hungry
drink from muddy puddles and shelter
from constant shelling and bombardments
dodging bombs bullets and land mines as
they fled
the war in ukraine has also had a
devastating impact on the most
vulnerable children globally as food and
fuel prices spike to all time high
children already affected by conflict
and climate crisis across the world
from afghanistan to yemen and the horn
of africa are now paying a deadly price
for another war far from their doorsteps
the repercussions of the war in ukraine
will continue to ripple across the globe
excellencies ukrainian children have
been uprooted from their homes separated
from caregivers and directly exposed to
war
their schools have been destroyed and
the critical infrastructure essential to
their survival and well-being included
hospitals and water and sanitation
systems are being devastated by the
fighting
ukrainian children tell us that they
want to reunite with their families to
return to their communities
to go to school and play in their
neighborhoods
children are resilient but they
shouldn't have to be
they have already paid an unconscionably
high price in this war
we must do everything possible to help
ensure it doesn't also cost them their
futures
once again as humanitarians we will do
everything we can to continue meeting
the needs of children affected by this
war to provide safety stability
and protection but this will never be
enough
ultimately children need an end to this
war their futures hang in the balance
thank you mr president
i thank mr abdi for his briefing
i would like to draw the attention of
speakers to paragraph 22 of note 507
which encourages all participants
in council meetings to deliver their
statements in five minutes or less
in line with the security council's
commitment to making more effective use
of open meetings
and i now give the floor to those
council members who wish to make
statements
i give the floor to the representative
of mexico
their briefings
regarding the terrible impact that the
conflict in ukraine is having on the
lives of children hence why my country
and france requested this meeting
a cessation of facilities is not being
reached the priorities of the
international community must be
humanitarian assistance the protection
of the civilian population particularly
the
most vulnerable groups such as children
and avoiding greater harm to basic
infrastructure for their survival
attackers
such as that against a school in the
johannesburg
region are absolutely unacceptable and
reprehensible
attacking schools is a clear violation
of international humanitarian law
to which we must not turn a blind eye
in this context
we are following closely the work of the
prosecutor of the international
criminals
we regret the fact that this incident in
luhansk is not an isolated case
of explosive weapons
against schools
near schools uh higher education
institutions and the access routes there
too must be avoided at all times
moreover armed forces must be
sufficiently well trained to avoid
affecting the civilian population
mr president the impact of the war on
children is simply devastating
as has been indicated by unicef
two thirds of ukrainian children have
been displaced by the
and conflict the majority of cases they
have had to leave the only home that
they've known
this conflict is also affecting the
mental health and psychosocial
well-being of an entire generation
and the constant bombing and the
psychological harassment caused by the
warnings for imminent attacks
and we believe it's necessary to
delineate comprehensive
of sexual violence against children
for which support services are extremely
limited
effects on
health facilities is also leading to a
deterioration of sexual and reproductive
health services
and neonatal care
the massive wave of displacement has
made children and adolescents
a target for people trafficking networks
unaccompanied
unaccompanied minors and those separated
from their families are particularly
vulnerable
we call on host countries and
institutions such as the unodc and
interpol to address these new
circumstances and to register and
identify
we cannot forget to mention the
situation of children with disabilities
whose vulnerability is all the more
acute
in addition mexico underscores the
importance of ensuring that any child
from ukraine or any other country is
provided with the same treatment
there cannot be a system with two
different levels of standards in the way
in which we treat refugees
mr president
in closing
is a war against children and this is no
exception
that is why we ask the secretary general
and the special representative
of children in armed conflict to ensure
that in the next report on this topic to
include ukraine in order to establish a
monitoring and reporting mechanism
they should list those responsible for
grave violations against children and
address the situation in the working
group on children and on conflict
thank you very much mr president
i thank the representative of mexico for
her statement
i now give the floor to the
representative of france
mr president
i'd like to thank mrs
the russian army is continuing to kill
civilians including children and to
destroy
civilian infrastructure
we
all know that the number of
civilian victims is significantly higher
than the figures currently being
communicated
this black hole that it is so difficult
the cost of war on children
two-thirds of ukrainian children have
been displaced
and the majority of them are out of
school
france
attacks
200 medical facilities have moreover
been attacked or destroyed according to
the
attacks on whole and hospitals as well
as the murders and mutilations of
children count amongst the serious
violations of international humanitarian
law and
the rights of
children in wartime
we call on the secretary general to
harness all of the mechanisms
established by the security council to
verify the facts and to establish
responsibility these tools include in
particular the annual report of the
secretary general
these crimes will not go unpunished
france will continue to support
investigations to tackle impunity
by
providing its full support to the
ukrainian justice and international
courts including the international
criminal court
mr president
it is urgent
we call on russia to respect the order
handed down by the international court
of justice
bring an end to this unjustifiable
and devastating yeah
and to withdraw its troops from
ukrainian territory
the protection of the civilian
the protection of civilians and civilian
infrastructure is an absolute priority
this is why we
reiterate our appeal for an immediate
cessation
that have enabled the evacuation of
hundreds of civilians
to allow displaced children to have
access to education including
mr president
the entire world is being affected by
this
every day is increasing the
we once again call on russia to lift the
blockade of ukrainian ports on the black
sea in order to allow for the export of
foodstuffs
france will continue to step up its
efforts to counter the adverse
repercussions of this war on the most
vulnerable countries
in particular in the context of the
farm initiative
france
as announced by the president of the
republic
during the warsaw conference on the 5th
of may
as we have just found commemorated at
the end of the second world war we are
determined to continue to mobilize
for freedom
and peace
and across the whole of the european
country
thank you
i thank the representative of france for
his statement
i now give the floor to the
representative of albania
thank you mr president and let me thank
mr suya and mr abdi for the update
information
colleagues we meet again on ukraine
the war is going on with its destructive
path the overall situation is dire and
worsening people continue to suffer
lives of countless civilians
particularly women and children are
devastated because of this war of
aggression that continues unabated
if one would try to summarize the news
that we get every day from ukraine
including what we heard from the
briefers today it would be
continued shelling with mounting
civilian victims targeted cities with
large-scale destruction of civilian
infrastructure
persistent attacks of hospitals
healthcare facilities and schools
horrible crimes including extrajudicial
killings torture rape and mass graves
countless shocking personal stories of
lives uprooted ripped apart which will
never be the same again
we also hear about the continued
ukrainian resistance against the
continued war they did not want that
they did not choose
as the war goes on and intensifies so
does the magnitude of human suffering
over 7 000
civilian casualties
14 million people forced to leave their
homes in only three months
two months ago the u.n projected some 4
million people would be displaced by the
war
in less than 10 weeks that number is now
5.8
million and the new projection is double
8.3 million
this requires more financial support for
refugees and host countries to face
challenges with access to food housing
transportation and services
massive destruction of civilian
infrastructure has made life unbearable
or completely disrupted from millions of
people
because systematic destruction of health
facilities transports supplies and
warehouses
only severes only affect severely basic
services
mr president in this
background we are particularly concerned
by reports of unlawful attacks on
schools which deprives access of
civilians to education
it is unbearable to see a school that
used to be a school and now it's a pack
of rubble
schools just just like hospitals should
be safe places immune to harm free from
attacks
in ukraine today they aren't
an average of 22 schools a day have
regularly been under attacking ukraine
since the start of the war
disrupting the education of those 5.5
million children that are still in the
country
their school year has ended on the 24th
of february
at least one in six unicef supported
schools in eastern ukraine have been
damaged or destroyed since the stars
since the start of the war
only a few days ago more than 60 people
were feared dead after a russian bomb
flattened the school
being used as a sheltering in the
village of
bilohorivka and at luhansk region there
is no justification for such
recklessness
against this desolate picture we are
pleased to highlight that on a positive
note unesco global education coalition
composed of some 200 members from
private sectors civil society academia
acumedia and the un family is working to
ensure the right to education and to
continue the continuation of learning in
ukraine
digital devices we provided to current
teachers reaching out to hundreds of
thousands of learners to ensure
continuity of online learning
also
a high education e-assessment platform
will allow some 200 000 student students
to pass their examinations
dear colleagues
as the military aggression escalates
civilian casualties rise and war crimes
and crimes against humanity mount
reports and preliminary facts gathered
on the ground raised serious concern
concerns about
grave
breaches of international humanitarian
law in ukraine
a report recently published pursued to
the oec moscow mechanism analyzes a
shocking range of apparent war crimes
from rape to torture to deportation and
the use of human shields
it marks an important step
in a long road to a full understanding
of the legal and criminal acts committed
and suffered in the ongoing aggression
it concludes that among other two most
blatant attacks mentioned several times
during our discuss discussions here
the bombing of the mario paul maternity
house and children's hospital and the
bombing of mario paul drama theater were
where several hundred civilians were
killed constitute most likely an
egregious violation of international
military and law
and those who ordered or executed it
committed a crime
mr president
everything should be done to secure the
rights of children
and in this respect we call on dsg and
the srsg on children arm conflicts to
add ukraine as a situation of concern
in the sg upcoming 222
annual report on children in armed
conflicts in light of great violations
committed against children in eastern
ukraine between 2014 and 2021
as well as evidence of an alarming
increase in grade violations across the
country amid the rapid and ongoing
escalation of hostilities since late
february
thorough investigation must be carried
out and accountability must and will be
ensured
dear colleagues the seismic effects of
russia's war in ukraine are felt
everywhere
the stores in places far from russia and
ukraine are running out of cooking oil
farmers are scrambling to buy
fertilizers and governments are
struggling to respond to public disquiet
due to the sharp rays of prices
disruptions to the flow of these
essential goods are compounding other
supply chains
causing shortages and pushing millions
of people into hunger
there must be no mistake for who is
responsible
ceasefire arrangements for the
evacuation of
600 civilians from the steel plant in
mario paul show that it is possible to
find solutions it is possible to silence
the guns in the name of life when there
is a will
this should be extended to the soldiers
wounded that are still there
we support efforts by usg griffiths and
praise the u.n actress on the ground for
their contribution and encourage
them to continue their efforts
colleagues let me end with this
the senseless war must come to an end
the sooner it happens the better for
ukraine and their people to start
healing their profound wounds
the better for russia and the russians
to get out of a self-victimization
attitude the better for everyone
everywhere and i thank you
i thank the representative albania for
his statement
a small change to our list of speakers
so i give the floor to the
representative of ghana
i thank you mr president and the
delegations of mexico and france for
convening this meeting
i would like to join previous speakers
in thanking miss joyce misuya and mr
umar abdi for their briefings
mr president after several months of
violent conflict in ukraine and its
resultant humanitarian crisis ghana is
deeply concerned about the lack of
satisfactory progress in finding a
solution to the situation
it is indeed disheartening to know that
innocent children have been caught up in
the middle of this armed conflict and
sadly they will be the most adversely
affected by the horrifying situation
as the war continues to affect social
institutions education has undeniably
been one of the major casualties leading
to severe disruptions in the education
of children
my delegation takes note of a report by
the ukrainian ministry of education and
science that 1
397
educational facilities across the
country have been damaged and 102
destroyed by bombings and shelling as of
26 april 2022
in fact the reported attacks on schools
and other educational facilities across
ukraine may constitute gross violations
of international humanitarian law
particularly against children
on this note my delegation strongly
condemns the bomb explosion of a school
building in luhansk eastern ukraine on
7th may which resulted in significant
civilian casualties and we wish to
commensurate with the beret families and
the people of ukraine
ghana reiterates its call on all parties
to refrain from attacking civilian
infrastructure especially those whose
destruction impacts the lives of
children
mr president without the immediate
cessation of hostilities the 7.5 million
children in ukraine would continue to be
endangered by the escalating armed
conflict it is very disheartening to see
images of students forced to hide in
basements and bomb shelters and children
missing months of schooling which will
certainly impact their future negatively
the persistent human impunity and high
high-handedness against children schools
and educational facilities in ukraine
must not only stop fought with but the
perpetrators must be held accountable
for their actions
in the meantime ghana is still hopeful
that the war ends soon by peaceful and
diplomatic means so that teachers and
students can return to their normal
routines
in these difficult circumstances in
ukraine the first still remains that war
is usually traumatic for children
especially when they are directly
affected
the mental impact especially on these
children is likely to have devastating
consequences for several years to come
in this connection humanitarian efforts
should not only focus on the fiscal
needs of the affected children in
ukraine but also on their psychological
needs and emotional assistance as the
damage of the war will result in
long-lasting psychological
trauma
my delegation reiterates that the mental
well-being and safety of the children in
ukraine should be our ultimate concern
and should remain at the forefront of
action of the international community
including this council
at this juncture we wish to commend the
efforts of unicef and its partners in
providing education related supplies and
appropriate learning opportunities for
ukrainian children informant and
informal setting
my delegation calls on host and transit
countries to ensure that the best
interest of children including learning
opportunities is an essential element of
their interventions we believe that such
interventions would minimize the
enduring impact that the ongoing crisis
will have in the lives of the children
in ukraine and their education
in the spirit of u.n resolution 26
i would like to reaffirm ghana's
commitment to u.n endeavors to protect
their children in ukraine as well as its
efforts aimed at ensuring uninterrupted
education for their children
we encourage the continued deployment of
the good offices of the secretary
general in the international endeavor to
bring an end to the war and facilitate a
diplomatic solution to the ongoing
security and humanitarian crisis in
ukraine in concluding for the sake of
the lives of the innocent children in
ukraine we reiterate our call on the
russian federation to hit the repeated
calls of the international community to
withdraw all its invading troops from
the internationally recognized borders
of ukraine and pursue the path of
dialogue and diplomacy i thank you mr
president
i thank the representative of ghana for
her statement
i now give the floor to the
representative of kenya
thank you mr president
i thank asg madame joyce musuya
and wtad mr umar abdi for their
briefings
i also welcome the participation of
representatives of ukraine
estonia poland
and slovakia
mr president
the humanitarian catastrophe in ukraine
is deeply disturbing
we do not think
that it is inevitable
that it should continue
but we fear that the council
is settling into a familiar tragic
pattern
the military conflict is becoming a
protracted affair
in which the civilian population
continues to suffer gravely
and rather than diplomacy negotiation
and ceasefire being sought with ambition
far too much energy and attention
are being used to make and defend
accusations of violations of
international humanitarian law
we are forced to restate the obvious
that our responsibility
as a security council is to protect
international peace
and security
of course our efforts to advance the
humanitarian aims in conflict are
critically important
but the primary responsibility of the
council
remains
international peace and security
we must therefore
ask the council and all its members
to make every effort
to find a path
to negotiating peace for ukraine
and its suffering people
a peace
that respects
and protects ukraine's rights
as a member state of the united nations
the unfolding political situation in
europe
with alliances rapidly developing
that may entrench differences
needs to be stabilized for the sake of
international peace and security
if the security council
and the international community truly
embrace the preventive
approach
then
this is a priority
it is also the best guard against the
humanitarian crisis
that will emerge as a result of a
broadening of the war in the future
president
in regard to the present humanitarian
developments
kenya condemns the recent attacks on
civilian objects
including the reported bombing of a
school in glensk that's believed to have
been sheltering
about 90 civilians
we again urge all parties to prioritize
the protection of schools and other
critical civilian infrastructure
in accordance with international
humanitarian law
we commend the secretary general for his
efforts that resulted in the recent
round of evacuations to safety of more
than 170 people that were trapped in
their softer steel plant and other areas
of mario paul
mr president
we must not forget that this war is
impacting economies and vulnerable
people around the world
the disruption of food and energy supply
chain
is compounding the food and energy and
security especially
in fragile contexts and driving millions
deeper into poverty and humanitarian
crises
we therefore appeal for enhanced support
for other humanitarian situations
particularly in the global south
in line with the secretary general's
recommendations on the basis of
assessments by its global crisis
response group
states should resist export restrictions
and make reserves available to countries
with syria's
food insecurity
we urge states
u.n agencies and international financial
institutions to urgently implement
the secretary general's recommendations
time and boldness
are of the essence if this war
is not to lead to the escalation of
multiple crises worldwide
mr president in closing we call on the
parties to the war in ukraine and their
allies and partners to give more effort
to achieving a meaningful cessation of
hostilities
in the meantime we strongly urge ukraine
and the russian federation to offer
guarantees for safe humanitarian
passages for trump's civilians
particularly in eastern ukraine i thank
you for your attention
i thank the representative of kenya for
his statement
i now give the floor to the
representative of norway
thank you president
i thank the briefers for their grave
accounts of the humanitarian situation
in ukraine
again norway condemns in the strongest
terms russia's unprovoked war of
aggression against ukraine it has
created a humanitarian disaster
one which is the responsibility of
russia alone
the civilian suffering must end
the council's joint expression of
support last week to the secretary
general's effort to search for peaceful
solutions is a first step towards this
end
we need to see a path towards peace
president the ongoing attacks on
civilians and civilian infrastructure in
ukraine is having a particularly
devastating and unacceptable impact on
children their families and communities
the use of heavy explosive weapons in
populated areas is destroying homes
schools and health centers
with children at an especially high risk
for lethal and debilitating injuries
seven times higher than for adults
and we condemn the use of anti-personnel
mines and cluster munitions weapons that
will continue to kill and injure long
after the conflict ends
the most recent attacks by russia on
schools and the civilians seeking
shelter there demonstrate a blatant
disrespect for international
humanitarian law
these attacks are clearly in
contradiction of security council
resolution 2601
on the protection of education in
conflict
unanimously adopted by this council just
months ago
we call on all parties to protect and
respect the civilian character of
schools and educational facilities in
accordance with international
humanitarian law
continuing education even during armed
conflict is crucial including for
displaced children
their right to education must be upheld
president all ukrainian children are
affected by this war
many are displaced across borders or
internally in ukraine
we are particularly particularly
concerned about the high number of
children that are separated from their
families
unaccompanied children are in
particularly vulnerable situations and
are at risk of human trafficking and
sexual violence and abuse
access to child protective services is
key including child appropriate mental
health and psychosocial support
president norway is alarmed about the
situation for the many civilians
including children the elderly and
persons with disabilities who remain
trapped in the battle zone
all civilians including those in care
institutions must have access to
humanitarian assistance and safe passage
for voluntary evacuation to safety
we're appalled by the reports of
involuntary evacuations deportation and
so-called filtration camps
we're also deeply concerned about the
increasing reports of conflict-related
sexual violence including against men
and boys
it is of the utmost importance that all
survivors are insured sexual and
reproductive health and rights
the atrocities committed during this war
must be investigated and those
responsible must be held accountable and
we support the ongoing investigations
and we underline the importance of
utilizing expertise on child protection
children rights and gender
in ensuring documentation and
accountability it is also important that
the right to freedom of expression and
free access to information is being
vigorously defended
journalists must be protected
president i would like to conclude today
by commanding the humanitarian
organizations who are working every day
to mitigate the humanitarian
consequences of this war
especially local civil society
organizations which are doing a
tremendous job
but to truly end this humanitarian
crisis the war must stop
rosa russia chose to invade ukraine in
breach of the u.n charter and
international law russia must also stop
the war and withdraw its troops from
ukraine immediately and i thank you
i thank the representative of norway for
her statement
and i now give the floor to the
representative of the united kingdom
thank you mr president
and i'd like to start by thanking ms
masuya and mr abdi for their helpful and
informative briefings
over the past 25 years
the security council has repeatedly
recognized
condemned
and sought to address the impact of
conflict on children
while it will take time for the un's
monitoring and reporting mechanism to
establish the full extent
of the impact on children of russia's
invasion
there is already evidence
that russia is committing
four
of the security council's six
grave violations against children in
times of war
listed in security council resolution
twelve sixty one
one
children have been killed and maimed
ohchr reporting
suggests that at least
238 children have been killed
and
347 injured
although the true toll is likely to be
far higher
two
schools and nurseries have been targeted
across ukraine
and
as with the tragic bombing of the mariju
poll theatre
children sheltering
have been mercilessly targeted
three
there are credible allegations of sexual
violence against children by russian
forces
and as others have said
mass displacement has left children
exposed to human trafficking and sexual
exploitation
four
reports of forced deportations continue
with over 700 000 people
including many mothers and children
having been moved to russia
there is now
a very real risk
of a lost generation
and the continuation of a cycle of
violence
caused by russia's invasion
and the devastation it has created
to address this
we need to work together
first
we urge all countries
to endorse and implement
the 2016 safe schools declaration
designed to protect education in armed
conflict
second
the international community must ensure
that all credible allegations of crimes
on the territory of ukraine are
investigated
including grave violations against
children
whoever is accused of committing them
we support all efforts
to improve improve our collective
understanding of the situation on the
ground
through evidence and data collection
and the work of the monitoring and
reporting mechanism
third
the uk is proud to continue to play a
leading role in the humanitarian effort
in ukraine
delivering vital supplies and
life-saving medical aid to those most in
need
including children
but humanitarian support
is not a solution to the suffering of
children in ukraine
only the withdrawal of russian troops
and an end to russia's war in ukraine
will end the cause of suffering
i thank you mr president
i thank the representative of the united
kingdom for her statement i now give the
floor to the representative of brazil
thank you
mr president
we thank the briefers of ocha and unicef
for their presentations
we also would like to thank
france
and mexico
for their initiative to discuss the
impact of the conflict in ukraine on
children and education
children in ukraine
as elsewhere must be protected from the
harm of violence and under no
circumstances
should they be subject to violations of
international humanitarian law
international human rights law
and international refugee law
brazil is deeply concerned with the
continued reports of child casualties
due to the use of explosive explosive
weapons
mining related incidents
and explosive remnants of war
both parties to the conflict must avoid
the use of explosive weapons in densely
populated areas
including nearly schools or universities
or along routes to or from
to or from them
schools
and medical facilities should never be
used for military purposes
it is of the utmost importance to
implement resolution
2601
on the protection of education which
brazil was sponsored last year
the safe schools declaration which we
have also endorsed provides important
guidelines on this matter as well
in the face of conflict
children and their parents have to
endure
great challenges
there are reports of ukrainian parents
that out of desperations sent their
children abroad with strangers
authorities in neighboring countries
have identified children as young as
four
and five years old crossing state
borders alone or with barely family
or with barely
familiar people
for them
family reunification
should be pursued with great urgency
we cannot overestimate the impact of war
in traumatized children
furthermore with the with the disruption
of the school system countryside [ __ ]
country are white
their studies are discontinued and
compromised
with lasting impact to their personal
development
as the conflict persists the damage to
children's education grows starker
the cessation of attacks against
civilian
infrastructures is key in protecting
children from the harms of conflict
resolution 2573
provides fundamental guidance for the
protection of objects indispensable to
survival of civilian population
children forced to flee their homes to
ensure their own survival
are especially
especially vulnerable
brazil is concerned with the alarming
number of children who became internally
displaced persons and refugees
support
from the international community is
needed more than ever
especially to those children who are
unaccompanied or separated from their
parents and family members
as they are forced into the condition of
refugees or idps
children can become more vulnerable to
crimes including sexual violence and
exploitation
their physical integrity and well-being
should be a priority to all member
states
in line with our tradition of solidarity
brazil has been granting humanitarian
visas and residence permits for
displaced ukrainians and stateless
persons affected or displaced by the
armed conflict in
ukraine once in brazilian territory they
have full access to all public services
and social benefits on equal footing
with brazilian nationals
brazilian civil society has been
forthcoming immobilizing to provide
further specialized
assistance to help local integration
other brazilian humanitarian actions
include the donation of water purifiers
food essential supplies and medical
items
we shall recommit our efforts to end
this conflict and prevent the ukrainians
to have a lost generations of children
victims of trauma and without access to
proper education
the silence of the guns and the
withdrawal of troops may be not enough
to end the war but it would be the first
glimmer of hope for the ukrainians to
resume their lives with peace and i
thank you
i thank the representative of brazil for
his statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of ireland thank
you very much president and my thanks
also to our briefers this morning
assistant secretary general masuya and
deputy executive director abby i want to
thank you both for all the work done by
you and your colleagues to help
alleviate the suffering inflicted on the
ukrainian people by the russian
federation's senseless and illegal war
thank you again
president shockingly
two-thirds of all children in ukraine
have had to leave flee their homes
many leaving behind parents and
grandparents
all leaving behind the lives they knew
these children face the horrendous risks
of abuse trafficking and exploitation
this is unconscionable we have heard
reports of children
killed and maimed by indiscriminate
attacks
we're also hearing chilling reports of
sexual violence perpetrated by russian
soldiers with children reportedly
amongst those violated
that is apparent
we simply cannot accept such violations
of international law causing this
suffering and trauma not in ukraine
not anywhere in the world
these horrific violations must end
and those responsible must
will be held to account
president a civilian infrastructure
across ukraine continues to be
demolished by russian forces we must
respond to the destruction of hundreds
of schools
including
kindergartens attacks on schools in
violation of international law have
profound impacts on the children
affected
let's remember
as in the case of killing maiming and
sexual violence attacks on schools and
hospitals are listable
under the cac agenda
if this council is to protect children
in armed conflict and to seriously
tackle impunity we must support the
integrity and impartiality of listing on
these grants
this council recognized children's right
to education and conflict with the
unanimous adoption of resolution 2601
just a few months ago
are our memories really that short
our words should be followed by actions
collectively we need to take action to
address the disruption of education
through the provision of education and
emergency settings
psychosocial services
mental health support and health care
it is clear that child protection
capacities in ukraine need to be
urgently resourced
in so far as possible this council
should support un monitors and child
protection staff
ireland calls on the secretary general
and on special representative gamba
to consider adding ukraine
as a situation of concern in the
upcoming annual reports on children and
armed conflict
in order to further assist the extremely
important monitoring work carried out by
un staff
grave violations and abuses have been
committed against children in eastern
ukraine since 2014
and now with the alarming increase in
violation since the further russian
invasion two months ago we would fully
expect to see this reflected in the next
reports
we also call on the secretary general
and srsg gamba to use all tools and
mechanisms to address any cac violations
taking place in ukraine
and to deliver on accountability
president the most innocent of victims
millions of ukraine's children are being
robbed of their childhoods and of their
future by this war
denying children the right to education
has profound impacts on their individual
development
but also on the future of ukrainian
society as a whole we continue to see
the devastating impact of the use of
explosive weapons in populated areas
including on schools
now and long after the conflict the
contamination of explosive remnants of
war will have a disproportionate impact
on the children of ukraine carrying
risks of death or injury further
blighting their futures
equally robbing children of the
possibility of routine vaccinations
exposes them to critical outbreaks of
communicable diseases which can also
have long-term debilitating consequences
the evacuations from mariopol negotiated
by the secretary general and the un have
shown that it is possible to do the
right thing for civilians
and that the humanitarian notification
system can function
we must continue all our efforts to help
the people of ukraine
president the reverberations of this war
we know reach far beyond ukraine's
borders we also know
that they will reach beyond this
generation
we all have a responsibility to support
the people of ukraine long after this
war has ended
at this table we have repeatedly called
for the war to end
for the russian federation to withdraw
its forces and to engage in true
dialogue and diplomacy
however while armed conflict continues
russia must comply with its obligations
under international law including
international humanitarian law
we will not tire of making this call
we must meet our responsibilities
the children of ukraine deserve nothing
less from us
thank you i thank the representative of
ireland for her statement
and i now give the floor to the
representative of china
mr president
and deputy executive director abdi for
their briefings
the conflict in ukraine is inflicting on
children pains falling to their age
protecting children from harm is an
obligation under the international law
that must be fulfilled by the parties to
the conflict
china reiterates its call to secure
children and the infrastructure on which
they depend
and to give priority to children's needs
in evacuation and humanitarian relief
operations
we welcome the safe evacuation of
civilians including children trapped in
the assassin
still
under the coordination of the un and the
international committee of the red cross
and hope that russia and ukraine
will continue to increase coordination
on humanitarian issues and make every
effort to reduce the humanitarian impact
of the people
the attack honor school in the village
of belahovka on may 7th resulted in the
loss of many lives
incidents as such are profoundly
deplorable
schools should not be targeted or used
for military purposes
the related circumstances and the
specific causes should be verified and
established any accusations should be
based on facts mr president
the conflict has been going on for more
than two months and has uprooted more
than half of the ukrainian children and
millions of children have taken refuge
in neighboring countries
china appreciates the safe shelter
humanitarian assistance and
psychological support provided by
ukraine and neighboring countries as
well as ocha unicef and other
humanitarian agencies for children who
seek refugees
on the international community to
continue to step up relief efforts to
ensure that every child in need can
receive effective assistance
the risk of human trafficking sexual
exploitation and abuse faced by children
seeking refuge especially those
separated or unaccompanied children it's
worrying
unhcr
unldc
ohchr and other agencies to strengthen
monetary and support relevant countries
in taking measures to prevent and
eliminate violations against children
about disruptions in routine
immunization for children
and the rising risk of outbreaks of
epidemics such as measles
should be taken seriously
china supports who in cooperating with
ukraine and the country's concerned to
ensure that children can receive
vaccinations on time
education gives hope to children in
conflict and it's also a matter of the
future of ukraine
china supports unicef in helping the
ukrainian government to provide
educational supplies and learning
opportunities for internally displaced
children
and encourages host countries to
integrate refugee children into their
own education systems in order to ensure
that children's right to education is
not disrupted by the conflict
mr president
achieving peace is the best protection
for children
is the most realistic unfeasible way to
reach a ceasefire
and stop the war the international
community should encourage russia and
ukraine to return to the negotiation
track and keep accumulating political
conditions for the restoration of peace
china welcomes the presidential
statement adopted by the security
council last week on ukraine calling for
the peaceful settlement of international
disputes and supporting the sg's efforts
to promote peace
sanctions will not bring peace
but will only accelerate the spillover
of the crisis triggering sweeping food
energy and financial crises across the
globe and making children around the
world suffer the bitter consequences of
with children living in conflict
situations in afghanistan yemen and horn
of africa as well as the sahel region
bearing the brunt of the humanitarian
impact china once again calls our
parties to stay rational and exercise
restraint transcend prejudice and strife
and make a remitting effort for the
early resolution of the crisis in
ukraine and for children to enjoy a
peaceful future thank you mr president
i thank the representative of china for
his statement i now give the floor to
the representative of the united arab
emirates
thank you mr president i'd also like to
join others in thanking assistant
secretary general for humanitarian
affairs ms joyce mesuya and deputy
executive director of unicef mr omar
abdi for their valuable briefings
as we heard from today's briefers the
extent of devastation due to the war in
ukraine does not appear to have reached
its limits and its impact is
disproportionately affecting children
well over half of ukraine's 7.5 million
children have been displaced as a result
of the conflict and there are also
deeply disturbing reports of hundreds of
children having been killed and maimed
since the conflict began that should be
investigated
war is always deeply traumatizing
particularly for children and this
conflict is no exception and there is a
dire need for essential services such as
education and health care to be provided
urgently and to continue throughout the
course of the conflict
we know too well from our own region and
beyond the costs of conflict on children
and their education from children in
syria that have been denied an education
for more than a decade to palestinian
children facing continued disruptions to
their schooling to girls in afghanistan
who've been denied secondary education
since august 2021 to children in yemen
libya the horn of africa and sahel and
countless more examples from around the
globe
there is a lost generation of children
and youth who simply will never regain a
meaningful opportunity to learn
the children of ukraine could face that
same fate while this armed conflict
continues and we therefore like others
urge all diplomatic efforts to end it
and it is crucial that we redouble our
commitment to ensure educational access
in ukraine where the conflict has
already significantly disrupted
children's access to education and this
comes on top of the covert 19 pandemic
related disruptions that had already
negatively impacted children's lives
before the conflict had even begun
as the international community responds
to the urgent humanitarian needs in
ukraine education must be a priority and
it is also critical to ensuring that
future generations have the necessary
skills to effectively contribute to
their communities so we must think about
the period after the conflict as much as
the period through it
as unicef recalled children will have a
much better chance to recover if they
can quickly return to schools and to
some form of normalcy in their lives and
so in light of all of these difficult
realities i'd like to focus on the
following points
first we remain deeply concerned by
reports of the ongoing damage and
destruction of civilian infrastructure
including health and educational
facilities
the bombing of the school in bilhorevka
over this past weekend is one disturbing
example and unicef has noted that at
least one in every six unicef supported
schools in eastern ukraine has been
damaged in the course of the conflict we
underlined the importance of protecting
educational facilities and ensuring
continued access to education
second facilitating access to education
particularly for refugee children is
imperative in supporting children's
development and maintaining a sense of
stability in their lives
we commend the neighboring host
countries as well as unicef and unesco
for facilitating the continuation of
educational services including through
providing equipment that supports online
teaching in addition to expanding
digital education platforms such efforts
are invaluable and must be supported by
the international community
furthermore distance learning can
mitigate some of the disruptive effects
of the conflict and we've noted that
twelve thousand six hundred schools
providing education to nearly four
million students are now operating
remotely
third providing psychosocial services is
critical to ensuring children's
well-being during and after the war
children have been uprooted from their
homes and separated from caregivers many
children have witnessed or experienced
violence included reported sexual
violence and all credible reports should
be investigated
we commend unhcr and unicef for their
support for the provision of
psychosocial services to children as
well as their efforts to particularly
help children with disabilities
finally we reiterate our call on all
parties to abide by their obligations
under international humanitarian law and
we further underline that the protection
of children and all civilians can only
be assured with the cessation of
hostilities throughout ukraine and the
reaching of a diplomatic solution to
this conflict this is not only essential
for the children of ukraine but all
children globally living through years
of armed conflict none of these children
should be neglected by the security
council
the reverberating impact of this
conflict including through the rise of
food and commodity prices will fall
heaviest on the health and development
of children
in this vein we call on both sides to
remain committed despite the
difficulties to dialogue and for the
international community and this council
to support efforts to end the conflict
and establish a process for peace
we are encouraged by the secretary
general's efforts in this regard and
ocho's feedback to this council that
recent efforts to evacuate hundreds of
civilians in mariopol have shown the
goodwill that exists on both sides and
our grounds to build upon we must build
on that opportunity and double down our
efforts to support these initiatives
thank you mr president
i thank the representative of the united
arab emirates for her statement i now
give the floor to the representative of
the russian federation
mr president
we welcome to the meeting the deputy
executive director for programmes of
unicef mr omar abdi
the deputy
as well and we've listened very closely
to their briefings
today a number of delegations have
spoken on subjects other than children
in education which was the subject of
today's meeting but i'm not going to
respond to this i'm going to concentrate
on children and education
we think that the subject of today's
meeting
is more than
and that's because the focus of our
attention is not just children
but also their education
which is the basis for who they become
as people
for more than eight years in ukraine the
regime in kiev has carried out a civil
war against its own population
the plans that the authorities and the
maidan had on towards children in
donbass became clear after the words of
petro poroshenko in 2014 about the
inhabitants of the donbass citizens of
the ukraine his own citizens
he said we will have work they will not
we support our people children and
pensioners
and they will not
our children will go to schools and
nurseries but their children will sit in
cellars
this is how we will win this war
end of quote
unlike many other people
kept
the authorities in kiev have bombarded
the people in donbass and have prevented
children from coming out of these
sellers
schools have also been targeted
hospitals
nursery schools and also key parts of
infrastructure
as a result of bombardment by the
ukrainian armed forces more than 100
children have died
there is a tradition of placing flowers
in the alley of the angels this is a
memorial to children who've died at the
hands of ukrainian military who've taken
up arms against their own people
today
with the aims of education
ukrainian
incidents of educational facilities
being damaged were established and more
than half of these were schools and
kindergartens this spring in don mass
once again children are dying under
ukrainian shelters
there's a number
of um of um orphans who are also
increasing because their parents died
under bombardments from the ukrainian
army
russia is helping the people of
donetsk and lugansk where it can
according to data since the beginning of
may more than 190 000 children have come
to russia
some of them have arrived without
of arrived with their guardians and
their legal representatives and from the
boarding schools in dpr and lpr more
than 1200 children have arrived we're
working closely with the authorities
to
on adoption for children who are orphans
child orphans
we're also making use of temporary care
for the children which allows us to
place them temporarily in russian
families
we're sending humanitarian assistance to
children in donbass with regard to child
refugees we're organizing a process to
set children up in school
and making use of all the different
options conventional school home
schooling inclusive schooling and also
distance learning
mr president the russian armed forces
are making every effort to protect
children during the course of the
special military operation in ukraine
we roundly condemn violations of
international humanitarian law
especially those carried out against
children
we think unacceptable both
premeditated attacks on children and
other people who benefit from protection
as well as the indiscriminate or extreme
use of force
and the use of schools for military
purposes
today once again we've heard from a
number of colleagues accusations towards
russian military saying that they have
attacked children including sexually
comments made by my british colleagues
these
accusations are absurd
we would therefore like to refer to the
primary sources here
in an interview with the television
company
the presidential commissioner in ukraine
on the right to the children of the
child
chuck get us
at
the prosecutor general of ukraine
doesn't have any confirmed facts
many buildings
educational facilities in towns where
active military activity is going on are
being used by ukrainian military as base
points as a result of which they have
been significantly damaged
we also have the firm impression that
norms of international humanitarian law
exist for anybody but not for kiev
and other children's educational
facilities have been seized by the
ukrainian authorities and that's not an
exception but a rule
this inhumane method of carrying out
military activities jeopardizing the
lives of children depriving them of
their right to education
and destroying the educational
infrastructure of ukraine
deliberate
destruction of civilian objects is also
the students teaching them how to use
firearms against separatists and
occupiers
the total ukrainianization of education
and the rewriting of the joint pages of
history of the russian and ukrainian
nations is what's being done by the
ministry of education and science in
ukraine in 2016
this authority
and i quote taking into account the
historic events of recent years end
quote established 25 educational
programs
the broadest
step change was on programs on history
and geography
if you believe it then the forefathers
of the french the spaniards and the
portuguese the turks and even jews came
from ukraine
my french colleague nicola did you know
that you in fact are ukrainian well if
you don't believe me then just read this
textbook
logic here since the french were from
the gauls then they came from
galiciana which is now in ukraine
and do you know that according to the
authors of the textbook ukraine and
polls have slavic roots but russians
have recruits and also bella russians
are not considered slavs they are
considered
in the book the historic the history of
ukraine for year eight students edited
it says that
the ukrainian people has existed for 140
000 years
in the book the history book for year
nine students edited by torch
it says that by the end of the 18th
century ukrainians were one of the
largest nations in europe
here we should
first millennium of the common era known
as ukrainians and this is given that
nobody
called
the inhabitants of the territory of
modern ukraine ukrainians
even in the work of
the esteemed poet from ukraine who lived
there in the middle of the 19th century
the term ukraine is entirely absent
the inhabitants of those lands were
called ruthenians russians or in extreme
cases little russians but i'm not going
to get into this
subject that is so unpleasant for my
ukrainian colleagues there are a range
of different absurd examples from
ukrainian school curriculum and
textbooks there is for example a
ukrainian historian
and there's not he's not the only one
for example he asserts that
constantinople was a colony of of her
son which is
now off
which is now severe
and that the forefathers of the
scythians were heracles inhabitant of
crimea whose roots are to be found on
the island of horitza in the dnipa
and the ukrainian state has existed for
more than seven and a half thousand
years
the
famous of the 12th and 13th centuries
according to mr
genghis khan
was in fact called bogdan
if you don't believe me
then the author advises you to read the
secret history of the mongols where
genghis khan is called
and from this it's clear that he was not
a mongol at all but was a real ukrainian
also given that he fought as as seen by
the by the under the ukrainian trident
and yellow and blue banners and of
course his main conclusion is that
ukraine was the cradle of global
civilization and even jesus christ in mr
bubbix
as he said in one of his interviews
could be from galicia this is no joke
i'm quoting his interview here
some of you might ask why i'm spending
so much time on this podcast
of course there are many crazy people in
our countries who promote marginal and
very controversial historic theories of
course there are many others
and we have them in russia as well but
there is one nuance here and that's that
book is not any ordinary madman but a
very distinguished matter
and among among these mad
pseudo-historians in 2015 when
poroshenko declared that the country
needed to found a special ministry of
information policy
and in essence a ministry of truth
whatever you want to call it then the
temporary head of the community board in
that organization was indeed valerie who
in essence became the main historian of
ukraine
furthermore this person repeatedly
was nominated for the national ukrainian
prize named after
a state award for a significant
contribution to the development of
culture and art the decision to award it
is taken
personally by the president for works
and i quote which represents the highest
spiritual achievement of the ukrainian
people which increase historic memory
and the identity of the nation end quote
so he wasn't just some kind of misfit
but was in essence the father of modern
the modern ukrainian historiography mr
president
ukrainian children will finally be able
to continue their education under a
normal curriculum and won't be fed this
drivel that the ukrainian authorities
are forcing on them at the moment thank
you
i thank the representative of the
russian federation for his statement i
now give the floor to the representative
of gabon
merci
thank
and
the initiative to mexico this briefing
on the humanitarian situation in ukraine
focused on the situation
experienced by children in the context
of the war
mr president
the humanitarian situation in ukraine is
worsening as the fighting goes on
to date
almost 14 million people have been
forced into displacement since the
beginning of the war in ukraine
half of the refugees or displaced
persons are children because they place
more so fast whether these displacements
are towards other cities in ukraine
neighboring countries or further afield
they remain a source of trauma and
distress
women and children
who represent the greatest number of
civilians fleeing war zones
are also paying the highest price of the
consequences
of those children who have left ukraine
since the 24th of february some are
unaccompanied minors this increases
their risk of falling prey to all sorts
of abuse trafficking or exploitation
these fragilities are further
exacerbated by the daily difficulties
resulting from water shortages having
difficulty accessing health care and
energy the statistic
unhcr figures on children killed or
wounded during the fighting particularly
in the east and west of ukraine are
chilling
once again we appeal to the belligerents
to respect international humanitarian
law
civilians
the unhindered deployment of
humanitarian aid wherever there are
people in need without discrimination
the situation of children calls for the
greatest attention of the international
community in order to mitigate the
consequences of war on their daily lives
particularly with regard to their
schooling
it's important that we enable children
to continue their studies
we're grateful to unicef for
inventiveness that it has demonstrated
to continue to provide
schooling to child victims of war in
host countries
by for instance establishing temporary
classes or organizing learning
educational or recreational activities
i would also like to specifically
congratulate all of those countries who
have
welcomed refugees and have made
arrangements to provide urgent schooling
to refugee children from ukraine
we hail the work of unicef that is
shouldering its responsibilities towards
the children in ukraine by addressing
families and children specifically to
provide for their hygiene needs their
primary or specialist health needs
including psychosocial health and mental
health care while also ensuring their
safety
we're also grateful to all un
specialized agencies on the ground
we encourage them to work with
unicef to limit the trauma for child
victims
not the statistics
we've taken note of the statistics in
the latest unhcr report on the children
registered in dedicated centers and the
establishment of help desks to provide
information about family host families
and operational mechanisms that continue
to be rolled out in order to strengthen
protection for families and children
it's crucial to limit as much as
possible the chance for
mafia networks to benefit from the
chaotic situation of these children
mr president alongside the work on the
ground which seeks to respond to
critical humanitarian emergencies
discussions must continue in parallel in
order to find a political solution to
the situation with the aim of bringing
an end to the war
this is the greatest step that can be
made to help
these children for whom we are meeting
together today
a way out can only be found by dialogue
that's why my country appeals once again
to the parties to harness all
opportunities to resume dialogue
we call for resolute commitment to a for
a return to peace and security in
ukraine thank you i thank the
representative of gabal for her
statement and i now give the floor to
the representative of india
thank you mr president let me begin by
thanking the briefers from ocha and
unicef for their insights on the
humanitarian situation in ukraine but
particularly on the impact of the
conflict on children and education
we have carefully noted the points made
by them
children constitute a third of humanity
the most important third as they are our
future
they are also the most vulnerable to
suffering particularly in situations of
armed conflict and therefore need
additional protection and care
the conflict in ukraine
is no doubt severely impacting the 7.5
million children across ukraine
while the protection of the rights of
the child including their access to
education is the primary responsibility
of national government
the international community has the
obligation to do its utmost to provide
sucker to children affected by this
conflict
india is a signatory to the convention
on the rights of the child and
appreciative of the ongoing efforts
including that of unicef to alleviate
the suffering of the children we also
support unicef efforts to scale up its
operations
the conflict has also forced more than 5
million people to take shelter in the
neighboring countries and another 7.1
million are displaced within ukraine
out of these women and children
constitute the majority
we commend the efforts by the
neighboring countries of ukraine who
have welcomed refugees from ukraine and
especially for treating women and
children with compassion and dignity
as a country which has welcomed refugees
over centuries india knows the
importance and value of treating them
equally and with dignity and catering to
their needs and requirements
the impact of situation on children on
education of children has also been
severe
it has further aggravated the pandemic
related challenges that children were
already facing
there are reports that more than 900
education facilities and schools have
either been damaged or destroyed in
ukraine
the efforts of the government of ukraine
to protect schools and other learning
spaces students and children's
teachers to ensure
uninterrupted education for children
needs unequivocal support of the
international community
let us
not forget the situation has also
affected foreign students including
those from india india facilitated safe
return of 22 500 indian nationals most
of them students studying in various
universities in ukraine
we are exploring options to minimize the
impact of our students education
we appreciate the relaxations made by
the
government of ukraine for this academic
year in respect of medical students
india has been sending humanitarian
supplies to ukraine and its neighbors
which include medicines and other
essential relief material
just last week a further tranche of aid
including essential medicines and
medical equipment were handed over to
the ukrainian side
we support calls for guarantees of safe
passage to deliver essential
humanitarian medical supplies including
through establishment of humanitarian
corridors
we hope the international community will
continue to respond positively to the
evolving humanitarian requirements
the food security challenges emanating
from the conflict requires us to respond
by going beyond constraints that bind us
presently
energy security is equally a serious
concern and needs to be addressed
through cooperative efforts
we acknowledge the efforts made by the
secretary general particularly the
findings of global crisis response group
task team
while responding positively to the
evolving humanitarian requirements is an
obligation and responsibility
of the international community it is in
our collective interest to work
constructively both within the united
nations and outside towards seeking an
early solution to the conflict
since the beginning of the ukrainian
conflict india stood for peace dialogue
and diplomacy
we believe that no solution can be
arrived at by shedding blood and at the
cost of innocent lives especially those
of women and children
allow me to reiterate the importance of
u.n guiding principles of humanitarian
assistance once again
humanitarian action must always be
guided by the principles of humanitarian
assistance that is humanity neutrality
impartiality and independence these
measures should not be politicized
in conclusion mr president
we continue to reiterate that the global
order is anchored in international law
the un charter and respect for the inter
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
states i thank you
i thank the representative of india for
his statement i shall now make a
statement in my capacity as the
representative of the united states
thank you assistant secretary general
masuya and deputy executive director
abdi for your very insightful briefings
which provide the council
and the watching global community
an opportunity to hear
to hear of the immense suffering that
has resulted from this unnecessary and
brutal war
especially the suffering russia's
inflicting on children in ukraine
your briefings underscore what all of us
all of us who do not live in russia have
seen on our screens and in the media for
the last two and a half months
children in ukraine have been displaced
hurt orphaned or killed
of the nearly 14 million people forced
to flee their homes since the conflict
escalated approximately half our
innocent children
children who deserve a chance to live
grow and thrive but instead are
struggling every day to survive
in horrific circumstances
the danger to children is only
increasing
growing numbers of hospitals and schools
have been destroyed as we're hearing
in the first five weeks since the
february 24th invasion an average of 22
schools were struck
every day
since this war began there has been more
than 200 attacks on health care
facilities in schools
we heard news this past weekend as other
members have have mentioned of a bomb
hitting a school in the eastern
ukrainian town of bilo harifka
it killed as many as 60 people including
many children
and reliable reports indicate that when
first responders arrived at the school
to assist victims of the bombing
russia's forces opened fire on them
we've all seen devastating and gruesome
images of mass graves
there are reports of individuals
executed on mass bodies marked with
unequivocal signs of torture and now we
are hearing more and more horrific
accounts
of sexual violence against women and
girls as well as boys and lgbtq persons
the united states is particularly
concerned about the situation in kerasan
where russian forces have reportedly
removed local officials and installed an
illegitimate pro-russian puppet
administration
in recent days these illegitimate
proxies
have increasingly indicated an intention
to petition
russia to annex khersan
russia is clearly seeking to assimilate
these regions into its orbit and for the
children of kerasan
this would have grave consequences
for example schools would be forced to
adopt the russian curriculum with the
goal of trying to erase all signs of
ukrainian adult identity or ukrainian
culture
in addition to fearing every waking day
for their lives and safety displacement
poses particular risks for children they
become increasingly vulnerable
to human trafficking and other forms of
exploitation and abuse
this is even more acute for those
children who are unaccompanied or have
been separated from their parents or
caregivers
ukrainians have reportedly been deported
to russia and processed through
so-called
filtration camps
many of them children
meanwhile russia's commissioner for
children's rights
maria lavova balova has touted efforts
to fast-track the adoption of children
from ukraine within russia
children are being exposed to extreme
violence fear and anxiety this can have
major psychological effects on children
that will impact for generations
unless appropriate support is provided
the trauma associated with these
experiences can have serious and
enduring negative consequences on their
cognitive development for years to come
many on this council have just now
called for diplomacy to resolve this
crisis
we agree
that diplomacy and dialogue are
essential to resolve this crisis
and russia should show its commitment to
pursuing a peaceful resolution by
silencing the guns and withdrawing its
forces from ukraine
we call again on russia
to end its war on ukraine and to abide
by its obligations under international
humanitarian law
including those regarding taking
feasible precautions to avoid and to
minimize
harm to civilians including children
additionally all parties to the conflict
should urgently facilitate safe and
unhindered access for medical and
humanitarian workers and supplies in
order to ensure the provision of
necessary humanitarian assistance
and allow safe passage for those seeking
to flee including children
we join others in calling on the un
secretary general and the special
representative of the secretary general
for children and armed conflict
to add ukraine as a situation of concern
in the upcoming annual report on
children in armed conflict
given the scale and nature of reported
violations and abuses committed by
russia against children in eastern
ukraine between 2014 and 2021
and the evidence of alarming increases
in violations and abuses by russia
across ukraine since february 2022 the
situation warrants a place in the report
the international community has an
obligation to protect children as almost
all of us around the table have said
children who are the most vulnerable
among us
member states should work collectively
to ensure that innocent children
regardless of the borders in which they
reside
can live without imminent fear of death
shelling and lifelong trauma
let us do our part
let us not forget the children of
ukraine
thank you
i now resume my function as president of
the council
i would like to again draw the attention
of speakers to paragraph 22 of note 507
which encourages all participants in
council meetings to deliver their
statements in five minutes or less
in line with the security council's
commitment to making more effective use
of open meetings
i will now give the floor to the
representative of ukraine
well thank you mr president
distinguished members of the security
council
i also recognize the representatives of
putin's regime
in the permanent seat of the soviet
union
perhaps as defendants in a future trial
for war crimes
and crimes against humanity
they should avail of this session
as pre-trial hearings
first of all i would like to thank
assistant secretary general joyce musuya
and unicef deputy executive director
omar abdi for their briefings
dear colleagues
admiration and pain
the sentiments of all those who are now
watching hazov style mariopol
courageous defenders hold their
positions on the full blockade without
any
replenishments
another day
another week
another month
every day and night the russian
occupiers tried to break
the resistance of the ukrainians in azov
style
every day and night they drop heavy
aerial bombs
they shell the facilities with heavy
artillery
and multiple launch rocket systems
assault groups of the russian infantry
are attacking non-stop
the defenders of mariupol have already
done the impossible they stopped the
overwhelming russian troops for more
than three months
they contrib they their contribution to
the disruption of the russian bliss
creek plans
can't be overestimated
mariupol has paid a heavy
price for this the death toll among its
residents over these months about 20 000
is double the amount caused during the
second world war by german nazis who
killed 10 000
that is the reason for the attackers to
show no restraint
in their attempts to finally crush the
resistance
that is the reason why we are extremely
concerned about the destiny of the
defenders of azov style
should they fall into the hands
of the russian troops
even during the evacuation of civilians
from azov style on the 7th of may
the russian forces continued to shell
the ukrainian soldiers
as a result three ukrainian servicemen
were killed and six were wounded
in violation of all agreed
arrangements
many in azov style have been heavily
wounded and they have no access
to the medical treatment they urgently
need
therefore we consider that the
evacuation operation should be continued
we call on the security council and the
secretary general to invest further
efforts to ensure the evacuation of the
sikh and wounded from the azov style
area in accordance with international
humanitarian law
they have to be brought to safe places
where their right to life will be
guaranteed
russian captivity is not such a place
for the servicemen from azov style
we are also alarmed that the
repressive russian practice of using
filtration camps
for ukrainians fleeing dangerous areas
is being consolidated further
given the inhumane conditions and ill
treatment the word filtration
can only be considered as euphemism for
concentration
it is outrageous that russia has applied
these filtration practices to civilians
who were evacuated from azov style under
the facilitation of the united nations
and the icrc
some of them were illegally detained
for instance during the evacuation on
may 9 ironically on mother's day
the russian occupiers separated a
four-year-old girl alice from her mother
a medical worker
only the little child was allowed to
leave the occupied territory while her
mother was reported to be detained in a
filtration
camp these actions by the russian forces
constitute a gross violation of child's
right to life and security
guaranteed by the hog and geneva
conventions on the iran convention and
the u.n convention on the rise of the
child
we demand russia immediately and
unconditionally release the child's
mother and ensure she is reunited
with her daughter
we call on unicef to use all possible
means to protect the rights of this
child
and other children who were separated
from the from their parents by the
russians
mr president the statement by the
president of the security council on may
6
serves as another example
immediately after the russian federation
joined the members of the security
council in recalling the obligation of
all member states
to settle their disputes by peaceful
means
it fired rockets on ukraine's odessa and
mikolaiv kharkiv and zappa regia regions
russia continues its missile terror on
daily basis
targeting mostly civilian infrastructure
since the 24th of february russia has
fired more than 2 100 missiles on
ukrainian cities and villages
women and children throughout ukraine
remain the most vulnerable groups under
the conditions of the missile terror of
russia
dear colleagues at least 226 children
have been killed and 417 wounded by the
russian troops in ukraine
there is no doubt that the actual data
is much higher
as the occupied territory remains a
no-go zone for any credible
international mechanisms
every day of the russian invasion of
ukraine brings us new tragedies and new
crimes committed by russians
one of the most recent cases happened in
the village of
belo horika the lugansk region on the
7th of may
following a russian airstrike on local
school on a local school the only
building with a shelter
only 30 civilians out of 90 were rescued
the school once full of joyful children
was turned by russian pilot into another
mass grave
last night russia carried out an end
strike on novgorod ziversky destroying
another school
as of today about 130 educational
institutions have been entirely
destroyed and more than 1500
have been damaged
i reiterate that schools must never be
attacked or used for military purposes
targeting civilians and civilian objects
including schools is a violation of
international humanitarian law
mr president in violation of the u.n
convention on the rise of the child
russia continues its kidnapping of
ukrainian children
after forcible transfer to russia they
are illegally adopted by russian
citizens without observing any of the
mandatory procedures envisaged by the
legislation of ukraine
according to official russian sources on
may 7th more than 1 million million
ukrainians have been transferred to
russia
including 200 000 children
2 000 of them are orphans
or those deprived of pattern of paternal
care
the children's living conditions and
their state of health remain unknown
we call on unicef
unhcr and icrc
to demand from russia immediate and
unhindered access to those children
as well as to all persons who have been
transferred from conflict-affected areas
of ukraine to russia or ukrainian
territories under temporary russian
control
we also call on the secretary general to
use all the mechanisms established by
the council to monitor and report on
violations against children in conflict
mr president according to the to whho
at least 3 000 people have died in
ukraine during the period of the
invasion
due to the lack of access to treatment
of chronic diseases
the health ministry of ukraine reported
that as of today russian troops have
destroyed or damaged about 400 health
care facilities
under the circumstances of war the
treatment of cancer patients have been
completely stopped in ukraine
there are serious problems with access
to insulin and antibiotics
the situation with access to medical
services in the temporarily occupied
territories of ukraine in the east and
south can only be described as a
disaster
there is a storage of the most
basic drugs
the u.n committee on the rise of persons
with disabilities estimates that
russia's military attacks against
ukraine are putting the lives of 2.7
million people
with disabilities at risk
distinguished colleagues we welcome the
launch of the commission of inquiry to
investigate the atrocities related to
russia's law against ukraine
the resolution adopted today in geneva
mandates the commission to conduct a
special investigation
into war crimes committed by ra by
russian invaders in areas of kiev
churning hiv and sumi regions
the least includes arbitrary executions
of more than a thousand civilians
widespread
instances of sexual violence torture and
other violations
ukraine together with up to 50 partner
countries will ensure accountability for
all perpetrators
mr president
it is symbolic that one of the russian
rockets launched on may 7th destroyed
the museum of ukrainian philosopher
grigoris cavarada
in his doctrine he promoted humanistic
ideas
indeed
the current russia is too far from
humanism
the recent saber rattling celebration of
the 9th of may served as another
illustration
the entire world commemorates on the 8th
of may the memory of victims and those
who stopped the nazism
77 years ago under the motto never again
russia has made the day of the 9th of
may
a cornerstone of its ideology which is a
combination of a propaganda war hatred
towards neighbors
militarization and utmost disregard for
agreed rules
norms and values
we are grateful to all member states
that co-sponsored the joint statement on
the occasion of the 77th anniversary of
the end of the second world war in
europe and thus demonstrated their
resolute stance towards cynical attempts
to appropriate and exploit the memory of
the victory over nazism and to use it
for justifying this full-scale invasion
of ukraine
listening to putin
nowadays one can hardly believe
he is the same person who once wrote in
his op-ed for the new york times that i
quote
the law is still the law
and we must follow
it whether we like it or not
wrote putin nine years ago
he also wrote a quote
under current international law force is
permitted only in self-defense or by the
decision of the security council
anything putin wrote
anything else
is unacceptable under the u.n charter
and would
constitute an act of aggression end of
quote
edition for september 11
2013 under the title a plea for caution
from russia
nine years ago russian diplomatic
vocabulary still contained the word
caution
and according to putin's opad
russia's current actions against ukraine
should be considered as act of
aggression
because nobody attacked russia because
because no single decision has been
adopted by the security council to
sanction russian actions in ukraine
if it was not so tragic it could have
been funnier and much deeper fake
than deep fake putin videos on trevor
snow's daily show
in fact they are much closer to reality
than putin's envoy speaking here
not long after putin's hypocritical
op-ed about supremacy of international
law
in march 2014 the late putin's envoy
turkey
at least made an effort to keep up
appearances in this council trying to
find at least some justification
to russian invasion of ukraine
today's standards of russian diplomacy
have gone through the floor
and all masks off
russia is the only beneficiary of the
council's inactions on the issue of its
war against ukraine
at the same time i doubt that it is the
interest of
of 14 security council members to
tolerate the russian strategy
of undermining the council's credibility
i urge the security council to
demonstrate
resoluteness in safeguarding this organ
and its mandate
from the destructive russian practices
and i do not apologize that i was not
careful listening to the dribble by the
russian ambassador
but i need to break the news to the
russian delegation
scientific evidence still suggests
that all modern humans
are descendant from african population
of homo sapiens
they spread out of africa about 60 000
years ago and i'm proud to be one of
them i thank you
i thank the representative of ukraine
for his statement
i now give the floor to the
representative of estonia
thank you mr president
i am speaking on behalf of the baltic
countries latvia lithuania and my own
country estonia
i thank the briefers for their updates
on the alarming humanitarian situation
in ukraine
and the daily work by unicef and ocha to
help those affected by the brutal
russian military aggression
we cannot consider this dire situation
without making clear who by choice
started this war and who
can end it
the russian federation
which must put an end to its aggression
and the suffering of children in ukraine
the russian aggression has been
accompanied by killing
torture
and terror aimed at civilians while
demonizing and dehumanizing them in the
russian war propaganda
make no mistake
children have been and continue to be
targets for russia
for children
written on the side of a russian missile
that struck the kramator train station
was a cynical but revealing expression
of this
children born in shelters during
bombings
living through days of air raids and
destruction
stepping on trains leaving their homes
and families behind
the un has recorded 238 children killed
and over 300 injured in ukraine since
24th of february
as it admits a clear underestimate
hundreds of schools and educational
institutions destroyed and damaged
according to the un
most recently in billah horrifica
resulting in the death of over 60 people
after a russian bomb flattened the
school
children suffering in besieged cities
such as mariupol without access to
humanitarian assistance
in less than three months
14 million people
including two-thirds of ukraine's
children have been forced to leave their
homes
ukraine's human rights commissioner
asserts that more than 121
000 children have been forcibly deported
to russia
the forced deportations along with the
russian steps towards legislative
changes to accelerate the adoption of
children from ukraine in violation of
the un convention on the rights of the
child
need to be monitored by the un and other
relevant organizations
the russian actions represent violations
of international law amounting to war
crimes and crimes against humanity as
well as grave violations against
children in
conflict this includes killing and
maiming attacks against schools and
hospitals and sexual violence
russia's crimes are recorded and it will
be held accountable
we underline and support the role of the
icc and the un commission of inquiry and
the un monitoring mission in this work
we call for the full implementation of
the security council resolution 1612
as well as further resolutions on
children and armed conflict including
resolution 26
1
on the protection of education
we recall that russia a permanent member
of this council
has endorsed
and has to comply
with this
we underline the importance of the
recording monitoring and reporting on
violations against children in ukraine
to the security council
including the secretary general's
special representative on children and
armed conflict
we value the tireless work by unicef
other un agencies and civil society in
ukraine and beyond to protect children
we welcome the work of the un and rcrc
in coordinating the efforts to ensure
the safe passage of civilians including
children from mariupol
estonia latvia and lithuania will
continue to support the work of these
organizations
and to provide financial
and in-kind humanitarian assistance to
ukraine
in the total amount of more than 46
million euros
we have welcomed those fleeing the war
in ukraine and offered them access to
our education
and health systems
as well as online learning opportunities
and mental health support for children
in ukraine and those outside
mr president
this council
has stood strong in calling
for the protection of children in
conflict
it needs to be strong and absolutely
clear
in calling on russia
to put an end
to its aggression
and to the horrors it has brought to
children in ukraine thank you mr
president
i thank the representative of estonia
for his statement i now give the floor
to the representative of poland
mr president
members of the security council
excellencies
i would like to thank united states for
organizing this important and timely
briefing and for shedding light on the
situation of children in ukraine in the
aftermath of russia's aggression
i would also like to thank the excellent
briefers miss joyce misoya and mr omar
abdi
for their insights and more importantly
all their work in helping the youngest
victims of russian aggression
mr chair
since the outbreak of war
more than 3.3 million people as of today
mostly women and children
have crossed from ukraine into poland to
seek refuge
poland both as a state
and as a society makes every effort to
meet their needs
ensuring that children continue their
education is one of our top priorities
keeping in mind
then the interruption of the educational
process even for a short period of time
has long lasting effects and can prevent
students from returning to learning we
are determined to ensure that each of
those affected by war can continue their
education
depending on parents preferences we
offer support by enrolling children in
polish schools or providing them with
equipment necessary for distance
learning within the ukrainian
educational system
for those who want to continue their
education in polish schools we organize
preparatory classes which will help them
to find their way in the polish
educational system and to overcome the
language barrier
currently there are almost 200 000
refugee children from ukraine in polish
schools about 20
of them attend preparatory classes and
80
attend regular classes together with
polish children
the ministry of education has created an
online platform where various
educational tools are available for free
in addition the ministry organizes
special language courses for teachers
from ukraine who have come to poland
courses are also organized for polish
teachers including in ukrainian language
to make it easier for them to
communicate with children coming from
ukraine and better respond to their
educational needs
additionally i would like to present a
project of the polish center for
international aid in coordination with
kerr
as part of cash for work program
ukrainian teachers find employment in
polish schools and kindergartens as
assistants of refugee children
we also pay particular attention to the
needs of children with disabilities
children with special education needs as
well as their parents can benefit from
psychological and pedagogical assistance
in polish kindergartens and schools
students who are pursuing higher
education in ukraine before the outbreak
of war can also continue their studies
at polish universities moreover we
launched several programs offering
institutional and financial support for
academics from ukraine to enable them to
continue their research projects
excellencies
schools provide children with education
but they play a much bigger role in
their lives
in times of war
classrooms can and should provide
children with a sense of stability and
act as a safe space to learn and to
process the trauma
however across ukraine hundreds of
schools have been destroyed in
russian shelling and airstrikes many
classrooms are simply unusable after
being damaged or destroyed
even after the war is over it will still
take a long time to rebuild the schools
and other educational facilities
attacks on civilian areas including
civilian infrastructure are endangering
children's lives and their futures
poland condemns in the strongest
possible terms attacks against civilians
and civilian objects such as schools
hospitals and orphanages
all perpetrators of violations of
international law especially
humanitarian national law and human
rights must be held accountable mr chair
over 2 000 patients from ukraine are
hospitalized in poland nearly half of
them are children
a pediatric hub was established in the
city of lublin from where young patients
are being transferred to institutions
all over the country and abroad
it has to be stressed that ukrainian
children just like all children all
around the world were already dealing
with mental health challenges from being
isolated during almost two years of the
pandemic
now having left the comforts of home not
to mention their family and friends who
stayed in ukraine to fight
any move towards pre-pandemic normalcy
has been cruelly interrupted poland
offers psychiatric psychological and
other mental health social services to
help ukrainian refugees however the
needs are growing every day
mr president
poland is doing the best we can to help
ukrainian children in those troubled and
terrifying times
offering them safety of our homes in
poland among our families and the kind
of normal life with its duties and joys
we hope that we are able to save at
least part of their dreams and their
childhood and i thank you
i thank the representative poland for
her statement
and i will now give the floor to the
representative of slovakia
thank you mr president
i would like to start by
thanking today's briefers assistant
secretary general tsuya and
deputy executive director of unicef mr
abdi for their presentations which once
again shed light on devastating impacts
of the russian war in ukraine this time
specifically on the issue of children
and their right to education we
appreciate the
updates that you have uh shared with us
and
we were listening carefully and we will
certainly
factor
all the additional information in our
further work and activities
as the unicef's regional advisor on
child protection for europe and central
asia said earlier on the 6th of may
in
a press briefing
hospitals including nurseries and
schools continue to be impacted by
strikes
unfortunately
slovakia therefore categorically
condemns these attacks including the
most recent one in
bilo horika
in the luhansk region this attack
together with all the attacks on
civilians and civilian infrastructure
constitute
a flag flagrant violation of
international humanitarian law and must
be thoroughly investigated and justice
must be served
we also concur with the secretary
general that this attack is yet another
reminder that in a war civilians pay the
highest price and i add
children in particular
we have been following these
developments very carefully also in our
current capacity as a vice president of
the executive board of
unicef and as a neighboring and
directly affected country
according to
the most recent reports including uh
update from the ohchr monitoring mission
in ukraine as of the 11th of may more
than 230 children have
already lost their lives and more than
340 children have been injured
approximately
two-thirds of ukrainian children have
been forced to flee their homes and all
of them have been negatively
affected this is
a terrible and devastating impact on
on the future generation which we also
have to bear in mind
instead of enjoying their childhood
millions of
ukraine's children are witnessing the
horrors of war without bearing even the
tiniest fraction of guilt
for what is happening
they are being separated from their
families and friends directly exposed to
blaring sirens bomb explosions physical
and unfortunately even
sexual violence causing them
physical harm and enormous
psychological traumas
they will need months and years to cope
with if ever
they are stripped of their fundamental
right of access to safe and quality
education which in many cases prompts
their mothers to take on the main
responsibility for homeschooling
this is uh
a special achievement uh quote unquote
of
the russian
and again quote-unquote special military
operation and
i say it with
a heavy heart
or in correct words a child crisis of
unprecedented proportions and one of the
fastest
large-scale displacement of children
since the second world war caused by the
russian unjustified unprovoked and
senseless aggression against ukraine
constituting a blatant violation of the
u.n charter and international law
mr president uh just briefly uh i would
like to add
from slovakia's perspective
that
we have
already
received over
136 000 children
that have entered
slovakia and over 30 000
have been granted temporary protection
so far
children fleeing ukraine are provided
with
as complex care
and support as possible including uh
psychosocial assistance medical care and
assistance in connecting or reuniting
with their relatives and families
we have been able to enroll
approximately ten thousand children aged
three to seventeen
in slovak schools and uh we work hard to
increase this number to provide all the
refugee children staying in slovakia
with proper education
i'm pleased that
also
the united states first lady mr
president
could have seen recently these efforts
herself a few days ago she met with the
teachers with the mothers it was
actually on mother's day that she went
there to support them and to express
her
solidarity
and compare notes about
all the practical aspects of their life
uh the refugee children involved in the
educational process are also entitled
to a food subsidy together with our
partners from unicef and unhcr we have
agreed to develop a joint child
protection capacity building plan
for implementing partners and other
stakeholders in child protection
inclusion and education
slovakia continues to stand in
solidarity with ukraine and as a close
friend and good neighbor
we do and we will continue doing our
utmost to help relieve suffering of the
people
we appreciate the work of international
organizations and institutions aiming to
improve the humanitarian situation
and
i am also pleased to add that the prime
minister of slovakia mr edward heger
recently announced
additional financial contribution
which includes among others a
contribution of 130 000 euro for the
specific unicef program
and project
to conclude mr president slovakia once
again calls on the russian federation to
immediately seize hostilities against
ukraine
and unconditionally withdraw all its
troops from the whole territory of
ukraine this is the only way
how we can stop
our children from suffering
i thank you mr president
i thank the representative of slovakia
for his statement
at this time there are no more names
inscribed on the list of speakers
the meeting is adjourned